alright so the problem we are
considering here is following so imagine
that we have a population that happily
lives in its original environment but
things can't go on smooth forever so at
some point we have an environmental
change the severe environmental change
the population becomes Mel adapted and
like if nothing else would happen would
then be on its way to extinction and now
the question arises cause right so can
the population is Cape extension through
adaptive evolution and so this is the
key question that I mean all about this
year thing of evolutionary rescue and
yeah we've started to work on these
questions a few years ago and this has
been done together with and Hildegard
occur actually I mean this is part of
Hildegard's PhD thesis and also in
collaboration with Sally auto from
British Columbia and most of the results
are actually have just appeared in the
American Naturalist in January this year
hmm all right so um yeah what's the
empirical interest in these questions
and yet traditionally this comes from
two different sides on the one hand we
have I mean conservation genetics and
usually there people believe that your
questions like an evolutionary rescue
are really important but one must say
that the data they have is I mean not so
overly convincing as yet and the primary
reason for that is that it's just
difficult to make the case of
evolutionary rescue in natural
populations I mean imagine there are
very many cases where we see populations
that do this adaptive tracking of
environmental changes right so and this
has been well documented and there are
many other cases of populations who
don't succeed to do these adaptive
tracking and then just go extinct either
locally or globally but for this
evolutionary rescue we would have to
make the case that the populations that
were able to track and changing
environment would have gone extinct
otherwise and this usually is very very
difficult also considering that I mean
of many of these ecological data where
we have good yeah data for population
counts and so on right we basically lack
precise genetic information now where I
see in this first case of course right
so evolutionary rescue is something that
we may want to see in the second case
it's just the opposite I mean there its
rescue is the same as evolution of
resistance against antibiotics or
pesticides and this is usually case
that's much easier to make simply
because human comes with lethal
selective pressures and we do know with
that and populations would go extinct
without in these bugs too and adapting
and you are frequently much more
frequently than we may hope that they
would they actually do but yeah so as of
recently we still have a third source
right so where and we can hope for data
and some new data is being generated and
this is from experimental evolution and
of course I mean this is always the
field that the theoreticians love I mean
some of you and
have already also started to do I mean
experiments on the side of their being
theoreticians and so this is like a very
nice combination and yeah so in this
case of evolutionary rescue and the main
experimental work has been done by
Graham Bell and Gonzalez and when this
is their setup this is like your yeast
that they've played it here in an array
and then they have like a salt
concentration that increases like
gradient from likely a very low
concentration so this would be like the
natural environment for these for yeast
and then increasing more and more just
in this direction and then what they do
is just to increase the slope or
increase this concentration gradually
across this array more and more and at
the same time right and I mean this help
of a robot obviously right and they do
local and global migration or global
migration among these plates and then in
the end when the total population there
then arises and arrives at a salt
concentration that is lethal for the
wild type then they just record whether
there has been evolution of rescue so
they're starting with icons below the
bottom they gradually increasing exactly
grow yes exactly yeah hmm which for a
first experiment on this like is
something that is already moderately
complicated like yes a indeed like it'd
be too complicated than like easy theory
that we can do it would directly apply
to these experiments they just have the
gradient from the beginning I just kept
that gradient what WI's why this way I
mean this is what they did right yeah so
it's
yeah mmm this is what I would have done
as my third or fourth and experiment not
the first one but mean yeah don't know
all right so um this is and what we have
as like our empirical basis so what does
the theories say I mean one basic thing
of course is I mean the complicated
thing or maybe also the thing that makes
it interesting is that evolutionary
ecology cannot be separated for this
problem I mean we have like a declining
population this is this race of
democracy versus evolution so
necessarily these two things happen on
the same time scales amazingly little
work on precisely this situation where
we really have population decline to
extinction being possible in a model has
been done until quite recently I mean
there has been work over the
quantitative create basically something
with a fixed variance then then yeah and
then we see that of this variance that
we have fixed in the population folks
quantitative trait is large enough to be
able to cope with an environment to
change at a certain rate by hold and go
or Kiev it's and some work in permitted
populations are mainly by Eleanor and
uncle SP and but then I mean recently
this seems to be now and like a new
emerging topic there has been a special
issue in the proceedings be right on
this topic and people started to ask so
can we understand evolutionary rescue
under more realistic ecological
conditions because I mean this is
something that reacts to an ecological
selection pressure obviously so we
should have some moderately realistic
ecology in our models all right so and
this is also our starting point of
course I mean what we did is to consider
population structure and the reasoning
behind this is follows I mean
environmental changes will often be
rather gradual than sudden and in very
many cases
will also not affect the total species
range at once and this is even true for
unlike your antibiotics or medication in
the human body I means not all parts of
the body are effect in the same way or
at the same speed by the antibiotics
than others or other kinds of medication
and is of course them always true out
there in nature and populations inhabit
complex habitats mmm so since this is
really the first model that's done here
and all we want to do is to explore
what's possible what kind of effects
could you expect to see if you have this
combination of factors in the model of
space declining population size and so
on for example what is the role of
temporal refugia right so if we have not
the total range degrading at once then
you have the possibility that I mean the
by type still holds out in some areas of
the space and sends migrants and maybe
Lisa dapped and so on right and also
what's the impact of the degree of
fragmentation of a habitat who does this
make it and we are easier or more
difficult for populations to adapt
really and yeah also consider some other
factors that we do have in our model
this old question of standing genetic
variation versus new mutations so does
the rescue come from a variation that's
already there in the base population
when the new selection pressure starts
or does it come from new mutations that
only arise later on and also what's the
influence of competition may be that we
will may have between y types and
mutants and also this will be an
important point all right then I should
come to our model and so since this is
the first model we just did the easiest
thing we could think of and yes to use
an island model here right where we have
D islands he
that exchange migrants with a migrant
pool at a constant rate of em so all
send out migrants and receive migrants
from this one comment migrant pool then
we have like just two genotypes the
wiretap in the mutant that are connected
by a mutation rate of you I mean so this
makes things really simple here only two
genotypes and then and there the
original conditions what we assume is I
mean that the population sizes on all
these islands are equal and constant and
given by K there's a wild type M which
has a fitness of one here and mutants of
a fitness of 1 minus Z and which means
that they would aamir segregate here in
mutation selection balance them to form
the standing genetic variation in the
base population so Z can of course also
be one in this case we don't have any
standing generation right all right then
I mean the environment starts to change
and be modeled this like this that every
T generations yeah one of these teams
switches from good to bad and under
these perturbations then we have the
following fitness scheme right so the Y
type here has an absolute fitness of 1
minus R so that means it would just like
in within this team exponentially
decline plus of course as long as there
still is by type in these other teams
and there is like an immigration from
these others so we have declined glass
and immigration the population size on
the case Island like for long time
intervals T than wood and approach a
migration selection balance for the
mutant we have the following scheme here
so this is the absolute fitness given by
this mildly complicated thing but I mean
for
just consider this 1 plus s so which
basically means the mutant can grow
under these new conditions right mmm if
s is larger than 1 which we assume right
and then there is a beta term that
models the density dependence like so
the degree of competition that this in
mutants and experiences from the vaio
type in these new Dean's like if B is
large then we have a strong density
dependence this is the total population
size and the K theme here right and if T
is if beta is small then I mean there's
almost no density dependence all right
so after a while of course then all
these Dean's and have fully degraded and
now that and the Y type certainly
ability Klein to extinction under these
conditions and now the question arises
can the mutant is tablished to rescue
the population or not and we generally
have a rescue probability that depends
on all these and model parameters here
right so can be quite complicated but
actually I mean for this talk and also
mostly what we did in the the paper we
focus on two parameters of particular
interest and one of these is here these
r and r if you remember this is I mean
that measures the strength of the
environmental change this is the rate of
decay under the exponential decay of the
Y type under new conditions right and
obviously we have this question you may
think for yourself what do you expect
with this rescue probability or rather
increase or decrease if we have an
increasing strength here of the
environmental change of course if you
ask an average ecologist so this would
be the expectation that this should go
down and indeed this is also what's
confirmed in this experiment of bell and
gonzalez in this one case
of course I mean they only had two data
points right so that show the decline
with a with a faster like if you do this
increase than the slope what they did
faster or slower by then they had more
rescue in this lower case ok the other
parameter that is of interest to us is
the migration rate so again you could
think of what were you would expect and
they'd rather go down or up the rescue
probability again most ecologists seem
to think that hmmm gene flow is a good
thing or alternatively said
fragmentation is a bad thing of always
fragmentation is a bad thing for
ecologists right and therefore um if
it's them there's more gene flow than it
should go up it again and again by two
data points this is confirmed by the
experiment of Baron Gonzalez mm-hmm ok
now let's now come to the analytical
approach that we have here ok so the
model for doing analytics is likes in
its original form in too complex at
least for us so what we do is to
simplify it a bit mm-hmm and the first
thing that we do is that without density
dependence right to really can and
distinguish just like two compartments
right so in this model this is the part
of the habit head under the original
conditions and the part of the habitat
on the perturbed conditions here right
and then after each time step this will
shrink and this will grow and we also
have here a time-dependent migration
rate among these among these two
compartments them now right ok so in
this case we still have to
consider the following so we have a team
a wild type right in the this is an old
in the original and part of the habitat
as a function of time right this then he
exchanges migrants with them a wide type
population in the perturbed part of the
habitat and here we have mutation here
we have also mutation in here so here's
a mutant mm-hmm mutant original and a
mutant in the perturbed conditions again
we have here migration in both
directions so um how do we approach
something like this so I mean luckily um
yeah we only have new mutation in one
direction so we can separate the white
ipod first and do this this part first
sort of and we try to do this part
deterministically just like with a
differential equation and in the end of
course i mean we are mainly like you're
interested in this part this is the
mutant under the perturbed conditions
right so these are the rescue guys right
and we will want to do this by a
branching process alright so this is the
idea but i mean as you see still in this
scenario we have here there are migrants
from here to there and also everything
like so the inflow from the right type
and the migration rates this will be
time dependent so effectively
mathematically this is a problem of a
multi type like a to type time dependent
branching process right and as it turns
out at least for us this is still
something that's too complicated and to
get any explicit results right II and
therefore we still need to simplify the
problem a bit further the first idea
here is I mean what we do that means we
ignore this arrow right we say that yeah
migration doesn't really take us to
these original conditions but we do as
if I mean everybody who migrates out
again from this product conditions just
dies right basically assuming that
offspring that once yeah went here will
never come back here to these conditions
which will be a good approximation of
the fitness here of the of the mutants
is is not so good right mm-hmm all right
so this is the first idea and then we
will see we basically come down to
single type time-dependent branching
process and then we are in the game okay
so yes I said this is the idea no back
migration of mutants right so this is
the first sub case that we consider and
just this is the Y type dynamics and
yeah so this is a differential equation
that we somehow can do depending on your
time steps and exponential decay we get
some some step thing out of this or
whatever but this is doable right and
then here for the mutants under the
original condition so this is this edge
here so we just also modeled this
deterministically this is deterministic
mutation selection balance and and now
we come to the interesting thing this is
the branching process in the perturbed
Dean's here where we have like a
constant birthrate right but here also
like a death rate yeah there's just one
plus all the guys that really migrate to
the original deed
this de- small D of T this is the part
of the habitat that is live or under the
original conditions right ok so we
effectively then get a selection
coefficient here just like this
something time dependent as I said and
basically we can fit this in for any
single mutation to get an establishment
probability there are like they already
made formulas to fit in these selection
coefficients and we use those here right
and to derive an establishment
probability for each single mutant none
of these perturb conditions yeah once we
have this then it's easy to get a rescue
probability so this is just am done like
you like a Poisson probability here this
exponent would be the probability and to
that none of those I mean in the rescues
it and went and this 1 minus the
exponent and is the rescue probability
if this is the total rate of a twitch
and rescue mutations appear so and this
n rescue here is this thing right and
this for this we have three different
components that contribute to it one is
this comes the new mutations from the
wild type in the perturbed deems right
so this is yeah this transition here
right then we have the migrating mutants
from the unperturbed team so this is
this direction here and yeah all these
are multiplied by the establishment
probability of course and then also we
have like another contribution and this
is yeah what's called pre-existing
mutants at environmental change so every
time such an island switches from good
to bad we have still have some we have
mutations sitting there and we also need
to consider these right all right ok so
um and yet something will come out of
this I will come back to this in my
results definitely right
but okay I mean there's a second case
that we actually can do so let me first
and mentioned this and this is the case
if we have migration rate of 1 which in
our model just means that everybody
migrates back to the migrant pool and
then it's just redistributed to all the
teams in in the end again right and this
um yeah again makes things easy I mean
we can do the right type thing a problem
but like the essential thing is that we
now can do the branching process here in
the migrant pool I mean every generation
everybody will come back to the migrant
cool so this is a single compartment
this again will be a single type
time-dependent branching process
actually if we do this we get like an
effective selection coefficient in the
migrant pool for the mutants that reads
like this and you don't have to
understand all the details just a note
that he isn't are appearing here so this
is a parameter of the decline parameter
of the wild-type under these perturbed
conditions right that's not a mutant
parameter it's a white a parameter and
it just says that of course i mean if i
type heavily declines here it will send
fewer guys back to the migrant cool and
therefore competition of mutants and
white herbs in the migrant to will is
young more bias towards my new mutants
in this case and therefore we have this
in the selection coefficient of the
migrants is also affected by this are
all right and again we get the
establishment probability from the
formula before and the rescue
probability later on alright um last
case that we also can do right or first
we should say until now we have ignored
density-dependent selection here and we
also wanted to do this now if we include
density-dependent selection then we are
in trouble and this is because then yeah
the actual numbers of white types in
each
these stupid islands really doesn't
matter and yeah we can't use this to
compartment thing and that we have done
anymore and therefore I mean all we
could do is to make things really easy
and do a like a dramatic different
condition that we just put and migration
rate to zero in this case so then we
have independent islands really and of
course we then do these branching
processes on these single islands but I
mean it turns out that this is indeed an
interesting limiting case because it
does not only describe the case M equals
zero but also of course like if we have
to adjust a single deem easy to see and
also if a sudden change so that like if
T is zero and all the demes change at
the same time then all these three
limiting cases are described by the same
thing so again something that we can do
but now let's come to results right p
and again right here here as a function
of the severity of change you can think
again what you expect so this is what we
do see if we have no density dependence
in our model so like a decline them with
the severity and just like expect it for
either high or low standing genetic
variation but if we have density
dependence in our model then we see the
following and in particular of course
this is here notable that with high
standing genetic variation and density
dependence of action we get this first
decline but then it increases again all
right let's look at this particular case
in more detail so this is the limiting
case that we can can make with no
migration so this over the lines are
always then like
analytical results the dots are
simulations I mean always if we can make
it to do it i mean this branching
process approximation is excellent right
e and okay what we can do here is to
distinguish the contributions of these
two sources of yeah of mutants new
mutations here this is this lower line
and pre-existing chance standing
generation this is here and there we
really see that this increase is done by
pre-existing standing to the Declaration
so standing snow decoration is
responsible for this increase here he
again the question why really do we see
this increase how can we understand this
intuitively that's not so difficult
after all that's interaction of standing
variation and density dependence
standing generations the main source for
mutant elites and then we have density
dependence adaptation is only possible
with low wire type densities and
therefore like a fast decline of the
right app is needed because otherwise
all the standing Cena liberation is lost
them before it can get effective right
so before it can really grow mm-hmm and
this explains why in this case it can be
easier to adapt to more severe changes
but then we also have this case right
and this is the Levine model a meaning
migration rate of one here and note that
in this case we did not put in any
density dependent selection in the new
teams but nevertheless we do get this
characteristic shape of course I mean if
the severity goes to 0 then at some
point also the rescue probability must
go to one this is trivial it goes down
first but then we have this market and
increase here again and so the question
arises why do we see this increase in
this case even without denser dependable
and in selection now of course I mean
the reason that we've already seen here
is this our dependence of the effective
selection coefficient here right so that
in the common migrant who will we do
have competition among why types and
mutants still and this is what drives
this and if increase here again so
relaxed competition because of a lot of
white types dying here can be easier to
adapt to most of your changes okay let's
now get to the second model parameter
here so this is migration rate and you
can think of what you expect so this is
what we get with outstanding genetic
variation and now if you can think of
what would stand integration change in
this case what it does is this right so
get quite complicated parents in the
very nonmonotonic shape as dependent
here on the migration rate that's a log
scale mm-hmm first question by this
intermediate maximum here so this is
easy to understand actually consequences
of migration on the dynamics in the
perturbed deems like here and they the
migrants here so we have two conflicting
our contributions here first by type
migration is usually beneficial because
I mean of course like increases the
wider population size he and the
perturbed Eames and there's more
mutational inflow here from here to
there that could happen if we have a
larger sauce here right so and this is
basically again that is proportional to
M somehow and then on the other hand of
course the mutant migration just in this
case this is most obvious right if the
migrants here just die right this is
detrimental from perturb to original and
this corresponds just a lof of dose of
mutants and we roughly get in
mmm increase in this yeah the I mean the
increase of the mutant population the
perturbed conditions is just
proportional some to something like s
minus m and this explains this decrease
a little later on again but then okay we
have the standing genetic variation and
then we see that here we get the
secondary increase here and we need an
explanation for this or try to give this
and this actually is because of
consequences in the dynamics not in the
demes and other conditions but in the
demes and the original conditions on
that side right and these become
important if we have standing genetic
variation and therefore a lot of mutants
also in these teams right yeah the
wild-type if we consider this this just
faces some loss due to immigration and
we almost don't have any gain due to
immigration because it's so strongly
hammered in these new conditions right
the mutant has lost and gained four so
four mutants this is just some this is
about equal I mean these two sides and
this leads the relaxed competition for
mutants in the original deems right so
even if we do not have any explicit
density dependence here just because of
keeping population sizes high night
under the original conditions we
necessarily have competition of mutants
and white types of course and because of
finite population sizes here and this is
enough to explain this effect right and
then like this leads to migration
selection balance at about em over Z
here in these original deems and with
this we can then now explain the full
pattern the effects of migration of
outstanding genetic variation we have
yeah why type migration and will lead
1st 2 again proportional to
and then you have a mutant migration
reduced growth and the perturbed teams
of the if M becomes of the order of s
this is the s here right and then like
if the mutant growth in the original
deems is possible if M becomes larger of
order of the order of Z actually right
and here so the Z in this particular
case and this explains this secondary
increase here all right so with this I'm
already done at my summary hmm yeah
evolution your rescue ecology and
evolution intertwined and this
necessarily always in these models gives
us a large number of factors that we
need to include and our results really
show that it's necessary to include I
mean a large number of factors because
these strange effects only arise from a
combination of different factors and
give sometimes unexpected behavior the
first thing that we've seen is that
rescue for severe change can be easier
than for moderate change either due to
competition of by type and mutants in
the new environment or to do competition
of both guys in the old environment like
if migration is strong and when really
broadly should we expect this effect
right we get it regularly in almost all
cases in our model if we have strong
density-dependent competition and a lot
of standing genetic duration so these
two factors together really they have
Drive this effect right and now we can
of course go back and ask has something
like this ever been observed in data and
indeed I mean there is one case where
people have pointed this out this pns
paper of read and are on malaria so they
see like a fast eradication of drug
sensitive malaria strains that and this
allows for a quick amplification of
resistance types from standing genetic
faster than in cases where this error
education has been slow all right so
this is directly confirms to what we see
here all right second thing is then your
migration and there we simply have seen
that yeah there are a number of ways how
migration can affect this rescue thing
right four different ways actually right
migrants and the right type migration
increases source of mutations mutant
migration decreases establishment
probability these are the first two
effects then with density dependence or
competition we get two more actually
I've only shown one here there is one
other that I've not shown in a graph
here that vie type immigration increases
competition of course my time emigration
decreases competition the last one is
the one of the Levine model that we have
seen hmm and generally we would then
expect a non-monotonic dependence of
rescue on gene flow all right so but
then if you just want to keep a single
line as take home message from this talk
maybe this is the most important thing
that the presence of the wire type can
be bad for evolutionary rescue right and
I just with a few words I want to make
this point that this is even generally
true than just under the scenario that
we've seen here which has been
competition of why type and mutants
right so certainly one important factor
but like ongoing work really also show
us that we do not even need really
competition it also works for the
recombination and now I mean what we do
have we started to do is that we think
of situations where rescue is not only
possible to a single mutation but you
need to to get rescue I mean to drugs
for example right it's also called
complex rescue due to a double mutant
right and then we see this dependence of
the rescue probability on the
recombination rate here again this is an
intermediate optimum maybe
of interests or so to people like Dan
Weiss man right so even without
tunneling we get some intermediate
optimum here but then what I want to
point out is this thing like this is the
case for mild effect on the right type
and this is the case of a severe effect
on the right type right in this case the
problem that the white up causes it's
just that it's yeah that it yeah that it
makes recombination of the double mutant
and the right type I mean so much more
likely and therefore yeah say it
decreases presence of the bio tab
decreases there for the rest of mobility
but this is work in progress again let's
work done in collaboration with
hildegard hookup should really point out
that i mean the bulk of this work has
been done by Hildegard and was this I'm
really at my end thanks for ya
wondering am barely found
that bastard a creation of environments
of empire are are so strong a
degradation tomorrow so hyah are would
actually result in lower probability of
rest yes yes I'm wondering how he did
with these populations that rescue is
likely be the same genetic variation
given and below mutation rates relative
location and so only there's private
competition between easy straight so why
why do you think they actually found the
suspect when your work seems to indicate
that that might actually have lost
effect ability
yeah I mean of course there are several
possibilities I mean first thing of
course is that even like in our graphs
right and we first see a decline right
and then the secondary increase again
right so it's a non-monotonic thing
right and if your chest to try to do
this just with two data points right
something non-monotonic right so it's
maybe just not enough right no idea
right so if even if you just do more
than this I mean they this could this
could change right and and then of
course I mean yeah they certainly did
have rather low migration rates right
and and it depends then right weather
really like your competition is strong
enough to inhibit mutant growth for a
long time right and this I also don't
know right so this is the second
possibility that I see
so it's obviously very cool I found
myself a little confused by the idea of
having absolute fitness and some themes
and relative fitness others I wonder if
there's any gz waves or make it more
regular and it even the one with the
three humps might possibly be
and then you can start the model there's
absolute fitness in those teams and on
top of that have like a population
regulation in the indio teams and this
comes down into the to the same things
we even have done some simulations well
then it is I mean possible I mean then
it's a stochastic effect that in
depending on what average number of
offspring you have but not in all cases
then really like if you're really
unlucky that then you also don't fill
these old deeds quite fully right but I
mean usually they are just they're
filled by 95 to 100 percent or so right
and at that point there's just like an
external population regulation that is
just yeah effects mutants and do i typed
in the same way right and then to turn
this into a model right then it's just
much easier to assume a relative
fitnesses only like in the india of
teams right but it does describe a
scenario where you have absolute
fitnesses and on both sides and then
again of course and in the new deeds
there you do need the absolute fitness
because i'm a rescue and everything this
does depend only on the absolute
fitnesses but i guess of this one
do all your simulations with absolute
fitness's we did we did so we did some
of those actually and we didn't see a
difference and then we changed it and
yeah because it simplified things right
to keep this population sizes a really
constant K than you expect the spatial
arrangement of the deans to make a
difference for example here Yeshua I
mean this is a like a step that one of
the steps we would have to go to get
closer to the bell and Gonzalez think
right since he yeah he also did this
stepping stone thing right yeah so yeah
we thought about this for quite a while
because this was one of the lines we
were thinking of going on and in the end
we came to this idea that it probably
will really only make the major change
if we have this multiple step and rescue
thing right so if we need more than a
single single mutation and then we
thought okay we should do multiple steps
and such first like before don't know
when we will get to these complicated
things yeah of course there are some
changes but I don't expect that the the
qualitative patterns that I've shown
will really change just for stepping
stone in single point single rescue
mutation yeah so I was
similar line like what is needed basic
difference between your type of
additional rescue models compared to
especially structured models where we
don't have to change in the environment
but we just have a structured
heterogeneous environment and relate to
that some of the talents you seem to
scribe or find in miles of evolution of
plasticity where you basically have
initially you assist me as somewhat the
rescue and then you have XP the tracking
by Ephixa genetics in changing
environments across time but you provide
similar patterns that what you find for
that there I see that time in spice
somewhat the same I mean yeah so even
more closely related models record your
models of niche expansion right that you
have like a wider population that sits
in one team and tries to colonize like
another an island where the white up
can't live but maybe mutants can live
right in and indeed you do see some of
the same effects there like this density
dependent and effect has been described
therein a model also by gamma here it's
all right you do these theories
sometimes but the essential difference
always is that there's no ecological
timescale there right it's i mean that's
never this race I mean they always have
we'll have this yeah these niches being
colonized like than at one point if it's
at all possible right and this
additional time scale that you have like
say you need to be quick right this and
yeah has rarely been considered there
right and also like makes an additional
aspect definitely about this rescue
reskin whatwhat's here very simple
answer one very quick I just want to go
back to your original the ecology of the
original organization relative
inclusions it seems to me that that
especially consider conservation it's
not clear that the near extinction in
local populations or the monotonicity
with kids Fitness is very often go down
very much quicker as the density gets
close to ya for many organisms interest
in comfort and then secondly and not to
mention the fact that there are quite a
few resistance systems where there are
some co-op tivity that has a deal with
establishment so it's not a single is
then have been simple and finally most
of the pesticide resistance very often
involves a diploid genotypic differences
in fitness so for example typical in
this exercise resistance will show a
heterozygote will be more fit but
actually they're homozygous is less fit
and selected apart oh definitely I mean
you're so is this young yeah say then
please do a very different dynamics
would have any didn't I mean this is
absolutely acknowledged and it's just
the two quick comments maybe we see all
mods definitely much closer to this year
the resistance thing which are in many
cases just driven by a few low side
right then too I mean conservation
things where you have really
quantitative traits and I mean very many
genes are involved quite and also
there's not such sort of the data I mean
you have second thing of course I mean
this is the first try I mean to try to
explore this territory this is much more
to be done
though and today dominant effects work
sample like with the would be one thing
okay when you got this afternoon just
awful